we're gonna do something we don't
normally do we're gonna double up on
debt-free screams this hour because
Lauren is with us here from New York and
an extra-special
debt free scream welcome it's so good to
have you here thanks we're honored to
have you with us today thanks I know
you're supposed to come down Valentine's
Day but the Opole or vortex kind of
knocked you out yeah I guess so we kind
of kind of rearrange things a little bit
so how much debt have you paid off it
was just over fifty five thousand how
long did it take you uh Chuck just under
five years with a lot of delays okay and
your income during that time it was
anywhere from forty three seven to
seventy one okay all right just 71 all
right and you said you you you get
you've been through quite a journey
hadn't you yeah so tell us about it um
well this day was supposed to be shared
with my husband Mike he passed away in
October 2011 from leukemia and his goal
was always to become debt-free and come
down here and do this scream together so
I wanted to make sure it happened how
old was he when he passed he turned 40
on September 1st and he passed on
October 14th okay oh cool
so how long did you how long did he
fight to leukemia uh he it was about
eight and a half years on and off um he
was diagnosed in early 2003 um went
through chemo radiation bone-marrow
transplant
everything um looked like a success and
he was fine for almost three years
hmm and in the meantime we got engaged
and married and thought we were on our
way you are having cancer behind us and
then it comes back and then in yeah in
the fall of 2006 it came back which was
just a huge shock to us to the doctors
everybody yeah this all started when he
was 32 and and so yeah he went into he
beat it in a sense and then
comes back yeah many times it seemed and
it came back unbelievable so what kind
of debt was the fifty five thousand that
you guys were fighting against it was a
car loan uh to student loans several
credit cards and lots of medical bills
so you're gonna do your debt free scream
because this was one things he wanted to
do and his honor and his memory that's
that's beautiful that's pretty but
really the debt free scream just kind of
seems like yeah so what
after all this other stuff right kind of
yeah cuz I'd and I shouldn't say this
but I'd be in debt forever if I could
have him here absolutely no you should
say that and I would agree with you yeah
that would be a good trade it would
absolutely be good it's actually not a
trade that's on the table and never was
but um but it's one you would take yeah
for sure for sure so you guys were
married for just under seven years okay
Wow well you're brave to stand here on
the radio and talk about this I'll try
I'd probably be crying I'd probably just
be boo-hooing yeah I mean you're strong
but you've been fighting you've been
fighting through all kinds of stuff and
that makes you strong doesn't it yeah
and I got it from him he was just he
seemed to always be battling coming from
behind and he if he set his mind to
something he was gonna do it so he heard
us on the radio in New York or how do
you hear about Dave Ramsey um he kind of
knew about you he would hear it on the
radio and right after his first
recurrence in oh six he he realized what
a hole we were really in we had a
financial advisor tell us we were one or
two paychecks away from disaster and he
went down to the beach one day and he
scrounge around the floor of the car for
any change he could get to get a coffee
and he went down to the beach and he was
just so mad and upset and he said I will
never leave my family exposed again and
from there he was searching for a way
out and around that time we went up to
mean we visited our friends Jeff and
Joelle and they gave us
your book huh and he read it almost
entirely on the drive back to
Massachusetts and the amazing thing was
that he was actually driving so no he he
was he was just lit up he couldn't wait
to start so despite the fact that he was
back in treatment we we did our best to
get our snowball
that's an order and to really get going
with it but you still had some debt left
when he passed right I did we were about
I think about 10 or 11 thousand dollars
away when he way down to the car and a
credit card and it's funny that when he
went in the hospital either the last
time or the time before because he was
in and out a lot that last year um
despite the fear and frustration of
being the hospital again and not knowing
what was gonna happen he said to me we
should have we should have the car paid
off by now because he would be so mad
that this was gonna add to the medical
bills and add to him being um you know
on disability where we would lose 40% of
his income you know for months at a time
all those years so he was he was still
so focused on that he really he really
wanted to see it done and so he passed
and you finished up the last 10,000 I
did um he could never get life insurance
and of course before he was first sick
he didn't think about it he was an man
always healthy um so all those years he
and every time he got sick again of
course that pushed it back you know we
were getting life insurance forget it
so after he passed I did get some life
insurance from work and we worked for
the same company and the first thing I
did was was path those last two debts
and and be done with them which of
course was bittersweet and I never
wanted to do it with that money
no no but either way there's no reason
heaven smiling when you hit that button
and finish that last one yeah you know
he was
like go girl yeah no he was yeah yeah
that's cool very cool
well you're amazing you're tough lady
and you've been through a lot and I want
you to know that in the hospital
whenever used in the hospital we would
listen to your show on the on the
computer every day afternoon he said
when it's time for Dave and sometimes
he'd fall asleep nap and wake up but it
was always on huh man yeah well I'll get
to meet him someday I'll look forward to
that me too yeah very cool very cool
well I'm proud of you hey how you doing
uh better than I was
I spent a long time in a very deep pit
just iraq not not believing this it
actually happened not knowing how to
possibly go on without him this was
never ever the plan so I'm better yeah
um there will always be part of my heart
broken sure but um I can be among the
living and start to enjoy things again
every day that goes by you can breathe
again a little bit yeah yeah yeah and if
sometimes it just catches you I guess
but yeah that's cool that's the way it
ought to be mm-hmm you're working your
way through it
yeah yeah you're good yeah good well I'm
proud of you and I'm honored that we
were a tiny little part of a an
unbelievable story mmm and the good news
is you're set up and you you got a job
and you're making good money you don't
have any debt and so in a very real way
he didn't take great care of you
he really did you did that's very neat
and everyone get life insurance yeah Oh
mmm it's so important know when you're
30 and you know you just you know you
don't walk around that life insurance
because oh my gosh
I just don't know I mean it's it's
ridiculous
well you're you're awesome so Mike and
Lauren from New York have paid off
$55,000 in debt in five years making 41
now 71 thousand a year count it down
let's hear a debt free scream all right
this is for you Mikey three two
one we're debt-free unbelievable man
I'm I can't talk unbelievable
Wow now you just don't get that other
anywhere else this is the Dave Ramsey
show
you